pendant la Première ministre vous avez
annoncé la semaine dernière votre
feuille de route pour les semaines et
les mois à venir au-delà des textes
prévus le groupe démocrates tient salué
votre volonté d'apaisement et de
dialogue qui a toujours été pour nous un
principe fondateur de notre démocratie
la mobilisation de la démontré hier et
je veux moi aussi aujourd'hui encore
saluer le courage de nos forces de
l'ordre qui défend non seulement la
liberté de manifester mais aussi nos
libertés et au nom du groupe démocrate
de Laurent hommage nous sommes engagés
pour réformer notre pays pour que les
Français ressemblent dans leur vie
quotidienne plus de justice plus
d'égalité d'accès aux services publics à
la santé ou à l'éducation pour qu'il
retrouve l'espoir d'un ascenseur social
qui fonctionne mieux cet engagement de
réforme est d'autant plus nécessaire
aujourd'hui avec l'annonce par l'agence
Fitch la dégradation de la note de la
France la succession de crise l'explique
très largement mais doit nous pousser à
agir pour établir l'équilibre de nos
comptes réduction la dépense publique
mais aussi réflexion sur notre système
fiscal pour le rendre plus juste et plus
acceptable par tous
la réforme de notre système de retraite
est un premier pas indispensable dans ce
sens pour éviter de nous endetter sur le
dos des générations futures la clause de
revoyure que nous avons faite adoptée
permettra aux partenaires sociaux et au
parlementaire de ce ressaisir la
question le moment venu dans le respect
du rythme démocratique nous devons agir
avec plus de plus de détermination que
jamais si c'est au gouvernement de
porter ses réformes c'est aussi au
Parlement de retrouver le sens du
dialogue et de travailler avec toutes
les bonnes volontés au delà des postures
politiques pour répondre aux inquiétudes
des Français et aux enjeux qui sont
devant nous comment madame la Première
ministre comment comptez-vous organiser
ce dialogue même si nous aussi
parlementaire devrait être en capacité
de faire ce chemin je vous remercie
merci beaucoup monsieur le président